Vamos a hacer un par de problemas más,
acerca de gráficas de líneas rectas
y aquí tengo un problema que dice:
Un gimnasio está ofreciendo un
trato a sus nuevos clientes...
sus clientes pueden ingresar al gimnasio
pagando una cuota de inscripción anual de 200
pesos y una cuota mensual de 39 pesos
aquí tenemos 39 pesos por cada mes, y éste de aquí, estos 200 pesos son de inscripción.
Ahora bien la pregunta me dice lo siguiente:
¿Cuánto costará esta membresía para el cliente al final de un año?
Y bueno, lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta lo primero que sería muy bueno sacar,
es la relación precio con la cantidad de
meses que nos quedamos.
y quiero que te des cuenta que si nosotros nos quedamos un mes, dos meses, 5 meses...
la cantidad de meses que sean, lo que tenemos que pagar en un inicio son estos 200 pesos
y déjame mejor ponerlo todo en pesos,
todo está en pesos y entonces son
200 pesos de inscripción,
que forzosamente tenemos que pagar a este gimnasio.
Sea la cantidad de meses que nos quedemos...
ahora bien, a esto hay que agregarle
39 pesos por cada mes.
Es decir, si nosotros nos quedamos 1 mes
vamos a pagar forzosamente estos
200 pesos de inscripción...
y además vamos a pagar 39 por 1 es decir,
239 pesos vamos a pagar en total.
y si nosotros nos quedamos por ejemplo dos meses
pues tenemos que pagar forzosamente también estos 200 pesos de inscripción,
más 39 por 2
39 de un mes y 39 del otro...
es decir 39 más 39=78,
278 pesos.
Por lo tanto ya aquí tengo mi relación del precio con la cantidad de meses que me voy a quedar.
Ahora, esta es la ecuación de una línea recta
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b"
¿cómo puedo escribir esto, de la misma manera que está escrita esta línea recta?
pues bueno, esto es lo mismo que escribir 39 "m" más 200
y es que date cuenta de lo siguiente...
en esta ecuación "y" es igual a "mx" más "b"
"x" es la variable independiente, mientras
que "y" es la variable dependiente.
Déjame escribirlo, esta es la variable independiente...
mientras que "y" representa la variable dependiente.
Mientras que ahora en esta ecuación
que yo tengo aquí abajo,
"m" es mi variable independiente
representa lo que representa la "x" aquí arriba...
mientras que "p" es mi variable dependiente
es decir que "p" va a jugar el mismo papel que juega la "y" en la función de aquí arriba.
y este 200... este 200 es mi ordenada al origen
es decir ¿en qué punto interceptamos al eje de las "y"?
bueno, no es al eje de la "y" en este caso
sería el eje de la "p"
recuerda que en esta ocasión "p" representa
lo que representa "y"
y el 39 es mi pendiente.
y una vez que ya tenemos esta función
de la forma "mx" más "b"
entonces, pues vamos a poder graficarlo.
Y que tenemos aquí,
voy a dibujar estos dos ejes a mano y espero
que no me queden tan mal,
lo primero que sé, es que nosotros tenemos que pagar 200 pesos sea la cantidad de tiempo que nos quedemos
es decir, en un principio tenemos que pagar
200 pesos de inscripción.
Entonces estamos situados en este punto...
es decir, que en el mes 0 estamos pagando 200 pesos que son los 200 pesos de inscripción,
y después por cada mes que pase,
es decir si pasa un mes aquí...
y bueno, déjame escribir que
este es el eje de los meses,
y por aquí tenemos el eje del precio de lo
que vamos a pagar, de "p"
entonces si pasa 1 mes nosotros
vamos a pagar 39 pesos más...
porque el mes vale 39 pesos.
Es decir 200 pesos más otros 39 pesos por
este mes que nos vamos a quedar...
y nos situamos aquí, aquí va a ser el valor de 239 pesos.
Y si pasa otro mes, pues entonces tenemos
que pagar 39 pesos más
es decir 278 pesos, y bueno yo sé que la escala tal vez no sea la mejor o la más indicada,
pero ya nos da la idea de nuestra línea
recta que tengo aquí
y ahora vamos a responder esta pregunta,
lo que nos preguntan es:
¿cuánto vamos a pagar al finalizar del año?
es decir 1,2.3 hasta el doceavo mes
es decir, estaremos situados más o menos por acá...
y como se ve que la gráfica sería muy grande
y se nos amontonaría todo
entonces vamos a sustituir a "m" por 12
de manera algebraica
y que me va a quedar, que "p"
es igual a 200 más 39 por "m"
pero "m" vale 12, entonces más 39 por 12
estamos viendo que es lo que va a pasar en el mes 12
y ¿cuánto es 39 por 12?
2 por 9 = 18 llevamos 1, 2 por 3 = 6 más 1 son 7
y después ponemos un 0 aquí y es 1 por 9 = 9
1 por 3 son 3 y quitamos este de aquí, 3
y me queda 8, 9 y 7= 6
16 llevamos 1, 3 y 1= 4
468 entonces, 200 mas 468...
más 468 lo que me sale de 39 por 12
y la suma de esto es 668 pesos
que vamos a pagar al finalizar el año
es decir, la respuesta de este problema si nosotros siguiéramos la línea recta son 668 pesos.
Pero bueno vamos a hacer otro problema, Bobby y Petra tienen un puesto de limonada
ellos cobran 45 centavos por cada vaso de limonada
así que 45 centavos por cada vaso de limonada...
para cubrir sus gastos de producción ellos tienen que conseguir 25 pesos, así que 25 pesos...
¿Cuantos vasos de limonada tienen que vender para poder conseguir sus gastos de producción?
así que vamos a bautizar a nuestras variables "x" "y" para que podamos graficar esta función
voy a decir que "y" va a ser la cantidad de dinero que ellos están obteniendo, que ellos están haciendo
están haciendo... mientras que "x" voy a decir que es la cantidad de vasos que ellos están vendiendo
la cantidad de vasos...
que están vendiendo,
y bueno ya que tengo quién es "x" y quién es "y" como puedo ver a "y" como una función de "x"
pues voy a decir que "y" ¿es igual a quién?
bueno pues, cada vaso vale 45 centavos es decir...
0.45 pesos por "x" porque si nosotros vendemos un vaso pues recibimos 45 centavos
si vendemos 2 pues 90 centavos y así sucesivamente.
Y date cuenta que en este caso no estamos recibiendo dinero por ninguna otra parte
solamente estamos recibiendo dinero,
de vender los vasos de limonada
por lo tanto, nuestra función solamente queda
así "y" es igual a 0.45"x"
y ahora, lo que quiero ver y lo que me dicen es que ellos tienen unos gastos de producción de 25 pesos
y entonces lo que ellos se preguntan es:
¿cuántos vasos tienen que vender para conseguir mínimo estos 25 pesos?
es decir, si "y" vale 25
¿cuánto tiene que valer "x" para conseguir que "y" valga 25?
y me va a quedar esta ecuación 0.45x es igual a 25,
estos 25 pesos que necesito conseguir
y si de aquí despejamos a "x" me va a quedar que voy a dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre 0.45
esto se va y me queda que "x" es igual a 25 entre 0.45
¿que cuánto es eso? a ver 25 entre 0.45
y me da 55.555555 y esto lo podemos redondear a 55.6
pero bueno "x" vale 55.5 periódico
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que no podemos vender y bueno...
asumiendo que no podemos vender, medio vaso, 3/4 de vaso, lo que sea...
entonces lo que necesitábamos conseguir,
son 56 vasos de limonada mínimos
para cubrir los gastos de producción
estoy redondeando esta cantidad a 56 vasos
y esa es la respuesta, pero ¿cómo se va a ver gráficamente este mismo problema?
voy a dibujar aquí a mis dos ejes...
éste va a ser mi eje de las "x"
éste va a ser mi eje de las "y"
y si te das cuenta en esta ocasión no tenemos la ordenada al origen,
solamente tenemos una pendiente de
0.45 que suena muy lógico...
si no vendemos ningún vaso, pues entonces no ganamos nada.
así que voy a poner 5, 10, 15, 20, 25 aquí no me cabe...
así que volvamos a empezar, te voy a hacer un poco más grande, la escala va a ser mejor
10, 20, 30, 40, 50 y hasta acá 60.
Y entonces si yo no vendo nada
no consigo nada de dinero
después, si yo vendo 10 vasos entonces ganó 4.5 pesos
y entonces bueno voy a decir que aquí son
4.5 pesos aquí son 9 pesos así etcétera.
Entonces si Bobby y Petra venden
10 vasos ellos consiguen 4.5 pesos
déjame ponerlo mejor así, vamos a borrar todo y empezar de nuevo.
Así que borrón y cuenta nueva,
hasta acá voy a suponer que son 9, aquí son 18
acá son 27 un poco más arriba son
35 y bueno,
en 10 vasos voy a vender 4.5 pesos
o sea que estoy justo aquí...
en 20 vasos pues 9 pesos, en 40 vasos
voy a vender 18 pesos
y bueno, ya tienes la idea
de que la pendiente es como 4.5
y entonces si yo juntos los puntos tengo una extraña línea recta, vamos a suponer que esta es una línea recta
y ahora sí, si pensamos en el costo de
producción en estos 25 pesos...
cuando yo tengo 25 pesos entonces voy a vender...
y déjame mejor hacer un poco más
adecuada esta línea recta
porque esta línea recta no parece nada recta
así que, vamos a dibujar una línea recta que
tampoco me quedó muy recta...
pero bueno, ya lo estoy intentando un poco mejor,
y este que es mi costo de producción, me dice que cuando nosotros tenemos que conseguir 25 pesos
entonces necesitamos vender entre 55 y 56
vasos de limonada.
Y yo sé que tal vez no sea la mejor gráfica que has visto, pero espero que te dé una idea.